what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and spider-man no way
home is now out on digital i know a lot
of people have said they've already
watched it a handful of times since it's
been out and i love to hear that
spider-man knowing home is my favorite
movie of the mcu right now and it
definitely deserves to be watched over
and over again and since spider-man noah
home came out and was such a massive
success rumors have been going around
that a few more spider-man films are in
the works right now with the possibility
of andrew garfield and toby maguire
returning for new projects of course the
biggest rumors right now are that andrew
garfield could be returning to do the
amazing spider-man 3 finally and that
toby maguire could be returning to do a
spider-man 4 and today it looks like
we're one step closer to that becoming a
reality with sam raimi recently
commenting on him wanting to do another
spider-man film which is super exciting
but let's not also forget about the
rumor that there could be another
spider-man film with all three
spider-man in it again because i would
really really love for that to happen
but let's break down what sam raimi has
recently said about wanting to direct
another spider-man film what kristen
dunst has said about wanting to return
for that role the role of mj and let's
talk about what the future holds for
spidey and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest spider-man and mcu
news now you have to imagine that very
recently with spider-man knowing home it
had to be just such an amazing thing for
sam raimi for all of his beloved
characters from his trilogy to be
revived and brought into the mcu tobey
maguire spider-man the green goblin doc
ock it's just awesome and even in
spider-man 2 he put that doctor strange
little easter egg in there now he's
directing doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
that's crap
science squid crap
doctor strange that's pretty good
but it's taken and here's the big news
recently in an interview with empire
magazine about doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness sam raimi
expressed that he wouldn't mind
directing a batman film but even more
interesting is that he said that he
would be up for directing another
spider-man film in fact he said another
spider-man film would be before
doctor strange his direct quote is
spider-man would be ahead of doctor
strange but i don't want to put him down
on the list talking about a list of
movies he would direct now sam raimi
literally just said that he would rather
direct a spider-man movie before or
ahead of doctor strange and i'm assuming
another doctor strange film since doctor
strange in the multiverse madness is
done but he himself said it he has
interest in directing another spider-man
film which is really crazy to think
about because toby just returned so did
a lot of these other characters and
marvel studios actually didn't think sam
bramy would return but sam wanted to
return in fact in a recent interview
with empire magazine kevin feige recalls
the experience of getting sam raimi to
direct doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness where eric carroll and richie
palmer executive producers of the movie
and at marvel studios were interested in
sam raimi and sam's agent said well what
about sam raimi and they thought that
would be incredible but there's no
chance of that however they go on to say
but sam wanted to come in and meet and
in the first meeting it was amazing to
reconnect with him and see his
enthusiasm to jump back into this world
after his long absence raymie was raring
to go and he said i have missed
directing it's really the only thing i
know how to do so multiverse of madness
is bringing sam raimi back into
directing and he's now stated that he
would love to direct another spider-man
film and guess what toby mcguire has
recently stated that he's kind of up for
anything at this point toby and one of
the spider-man noah home featurette said
i'm open for anything i'm ready to go
and in fact just today kirsten dunst
said that she would love to join the
multiverse in an interview with
backstage when the topic of spider-man
knowing home came up she said you know i
joined that multiverse i feel like i'm
the only one that hasn't joined it i'm
like please put me in put me in the
lineup and then she jokingly says i need
to pay for my house and kids so we have
sam raimi back we have toby mcguire back
and we have kirsten dunst wanting to
come back as well could there actually
be a spider-man 4 happening there have
been a lot of rumors stating that
spider-man 4 is being talked about right
now over at marvel studios and sony and
this puts us one step closer to that
being a reality and keep in mind there
was originally supposed to be a
spider-man 4 with sam raimi and toby
maguire that never happened and it broke
toby maguire and sam raimi's heart it
was supposed to be with vulture as the
villain and apparently it was supposed
to be kind of violent and pretty intense
in fact we have seen an animated version
of unreleased footage of what was
supposed to happen in a fight with
spider-man and vulture
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so as you can see from that it was
supposed to be pretty intense now here's
the thing they obviously can't do that
story anymore we already have a vulture
in the mcu although he never appeared in
spider-man no way home but he is
appearing in morbius but what could they
do now for a fourth spider-man film with
tobey maguire well there are certainly
plenty of villains they can use they can
use kingpin or they could actually take
it in a completely different direction
and do a spider girl movie focusing on
the daughter of mj and peter parker or
the best option in my own personal
opinion is to continue from spider-man
no way home if there is indeed talks
about a spider-man movie with the three
spider-man teaming up again i think sam
raimi should be the one to direct that
movie we know john watts is moving on
from spider-man and is going to direct
the fantastic four film and plus not to
mention in a deleted scene for
spider-man knowing home at the very end
when all of the peters are saying
goodbye to each other tom holland's
peter parker says i'll see you guys in
which andrew garfield's peter parker
replies you know where to find us
implying that somehow peter parker could
find the other peters in the multiverse
and that's a great sign for the future
if we do indeed want to see the three of
them team up again which i think almost
everybody does now of course it's been
confirmed by kevin feige the president
of marvel studios that they are indeed
going to be doing more spider-man films
with tom holland in fact they've already
begun to work on some ideas and there's
always the possibility that sam raimi
could simply be brought in to direct the
new spider-man films with tom holland
and that's an exciting thought as well
because there's a lot that can happen
here not only could you bring the other
two spider-man back but you could
incorporate venom since the venom
symbiote was teased in the post-credit
for spider-man knowing home sam raimi
could get another shot at venom which
i'm not sure is something he would
actually like he's got kind of bad
feelings towards that because he said
that you know people hated it and it was
hard to accept that criticism but it
would be kind of cool to get that
redemption much like andrew garfield got
and no way home but if he directed the
new spider-man films he could bring back
the other spider-man in these movies and
he could set up new spider-man like
miles morales and spider-gwen overall i
think it would actually be a really good
direction for marvel studios and
spider-man to take but let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below would you like sam raimi to
return and direct a fourth spider-man
film with tobey maguire and kristen
dunst or would you like sam raimi to
take over a new spider-man franchise
with tom holland let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof